[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com this is just gross but
probably not a shock
Republicans are defending Donald Trump's
Supreme Court pick Brett Kavanaugh
against the sexual assault allegations
that are plaguing him at this point not
by saying he didn't do it
but by saying that if he did it it
really shouldn't matter that much
because it was a long time ago anyway
and of course this ignores the fact that
if he did it even a long time ago he's
still actively lying about it now so the
question is are you saying that we
should ignore both that he assaulted
someone a long time ago and that he's
lying about it today or are you saying
that we simply don't know what it is
that happened because those are two very
very different positions for Republicans
potentially to take and then more
importantly who believes that it
shouldn't matter because it happened a
long time ago legally yes we have
something called the statute of
limitations that may have passed based
on the alleged acts that took place but
if I told you hey I've got a great
babysitter for you she did steal from a
family she babysat from once but it was
a long time ago and the police weren't
called anyway so it's not like she was
ever actually charged with a crime do
you ignore that and you say well listen
it happened a long time ago I'm glad to
hire her to babysit my kids today or do
you say no we it doesn't matter that
legally she's not going to get in
trouble I'm not hiring her as my
babysitter I think most of you know the
answer and this by the way isn't hiring
somebody for one night it's giving
somebody a job for life
Republicans are okay with the boys will
be boys type of thinking the locker-room
talk to take a phrase out of Donald
Trump's vocabulary silly attempted rape
that failed
anyway I mean come on hormones and stuff
right
attempted rape only matters for Supreme
Court candidates if they did it recently
like is that actually the position that
these Republicans are taking and there
was a time I know it's hard to remember
now because of where we are there was
actually a time when Republicans had bad
economic ideas but they were it totally
failed people as individuals they are
now genuinely hypocritical bigots who
value ignorance and value
anti-intellectualism
over morality and some semblance of
intelligence and critical thinking and
this doesn't even really appear to come
down to whether Republicans are willing
to accept Cavanaugh's lies and put them
on the court anyway this actually
violates the rules of integrity for
judges and for lawyers these rules vary
from state to state and from federal to
state and depending on the body that
you're talking about and of course these
are guidelines it's not the law but some
version of a rule that says if as a
lawyer or a judge you engage in conduct
involving dishonesty fraud deceit
misrepresentation or the appearance
thereof you are not fit to serve period
this is super cut and dry
you don't even actually have to
adjudicate the sexual assault
allegations because of the other lies
but in total there are two possible
answers here this is like
multiple-choice it's very binary either
their position is that it's okay for
Brett Kavanaugh to lie previously and
possibly now and just make him a judge
for life anyway or you have to take the
position that lying is not okay and that
lying under oath is not okay
and it's illegal and you shouldn't
appoint such a person to the Supreme
Court period and even if you want to
defend Brett Cavanaugh's actions when he
was in high school or you want to say
well listen at the time it was a long
time ago we don't know exactly what
happened and even if he did it his brain
wasn't fully formed and the hormones you
can defend the
actions as a high-schooler legally and
say we're gonna let it go
legally statute of limitations of course
having expired anyway but you don't have
to put the guy on the Supreme Court for
life and make him one of the nine
highest judges in the land and we're
quickly learning that this is one of the
most despicable nominees to the court in
decades and also I don't know if you saw
this but Brett Kavanaugh put out a
really strange statement saying that he
wasn't at that party
how does Cavanaugh know that he wasn't
at the party at which supposedly
Christine Blasi Ford was the subject of
an attempted rape how does he know which
party that would be if he wasn't at the
party like is he saying I didn't go to
any pool parties anywhere that entire
year that's how I'm sure or is he aware
that there was an alleged rape at a
particular party but he's claiming he
wasn't they like it's the weirdest way
to try to exculpate yourself the excuses
don't work whatsoever and it's weird
because this is maybe something that
Kavanagh could get beyond because he was
under the age of 18 and you know many
people understand that people in their
youth make mistakes certainly doesn't
excuse it but he could still be
nominated and appointed and approved to
the Supreme Court despite that but you
have to tell your story and you have to
be straight with it you can't get away
with all these lies no and this
statement it reminds me of mr. Cavanaugh
do you know who killed this man officer
I have no idea who strangled that guy to
death strangled mr. Cavanaugh I asked if
you knew who killed him
I didn't mention anything about a
strangulation how do you know that he
was strangled right no no no I had
nothing to do with it and I wasn't at
the party at which she was attempted
were at which she suffered an attempted
rape very strange way to defend yourself
and maybe we'll learn more about it at
some point for months I've been telling
you that this relationship between
right-wing FoxNews radio host and
television hosts Sean Hannity and Donald
Trump is very very bad news for America
and we know that sometimes Sean Hannity
is the last person Donald Trump speaks
to before going to bed Hannity sort of
tucking Trump in proverbially speaking
colloquially speaking we know that
Hannity has become just a blindly loyal
supporter of Donald Trump's pushing just
any old Trump friendly narrative on his
TV and radio show that that comes to
mind or that someone suggests to him no
matter how outrageous it is and we know
that Trump is impressed with these
strongman types in politics like Putin
and erawan but we also know that he
seems to be equally impressed with the
strongman types like a powerful media
figure such as sean hannity so this
relationship between Hannity and Trump
had disaster written all over it from
day one and we've now learned that
Donald Trump recently ordered the
declassification of sensitive documents
because Sean Hannity among others told
him that he should do it there have been
Trump's about there have been reports
about how Trump recently told the
Justice Department to go ahead and
declassify materials related to the
Moller investigation which is absurd for
a few reasons including that Trump is
part of what's being investigated and
he's the last guy that should be saying
what should or shouldn't be declassified
related to that investigation Trump
wanted FISA warrant applications
released related to Carter page who we
recently interviewed he wanted FBI
reports about interviews with Justice
Department officials Declassified he
wanted messages sent by James Comey
about the Russia investigation
Declassified really a ridiculous request
and a terrible idea especially since it
could expose intelligence sources and
methods that are being used by the FBI
so Trump was interfering with an ongoing
investigation by merely requesting the
release of these documents he was
possibly endangering American security
interests again he was jeopardizing once
again relationships with allies who
might see this and say wait a second why
are we going to share information with
the United States if Donald Trump might
willy-nilly ask for that information to
be Declassified at any time that's what
we knew so far so Trump then gets
interviewed this week by the hill and he
said you know I actually haven't even
looked at those documents but people I
respect like Sean Hannity and cuckoo for
cocoa puffs judge Jeanine Pirro said
have these documents Declassified and
released so I did it
but I didn't even look at the documents
myself here's a transcript from the
interview that he had with buck Sexton
where buck Sexton says have you reviewed
the memos yourself what do you expect
them to show if so and then Donald Trump
responds and there's an ellipses here
because there was some other stuff in
between these these two sentences I want
to be very clear about that Trump says I
have not reviewed them I have been asked
by many people in Congress as you know
to release them I have watched
commentators that I respect
begging the President of the United
States to release them I have been asked
by so many people that I respect please
the great Lou Dobbs the great Sean
Hannity the wonderful great Jeanine
Pirro it would be bad enough if Donald
Trump was personally dictating policy
but instead the people he listens to our
dictating policy and one of those people
is Sean Hannity another one of those
people appears to be wacky judge Jeanine
Pirro and there are White House aides
who are now referring to Hannity as the
unofficial chief of staff because of the
influence that he seems to have over
Donald Trump I want you to think just
for one second let's all do this little
exercise sit back and imagine this for a
second it's announced that Barack Obama
has ordered the declassification of
documents that could expose the
identities of ten CIA agents working
covertly for example confounding
decision why why would you release
something like that and then a few days
later a George Stephanopoulos interviews
Barack Obama and Obama says honestly I
don't even know what the point of it was
I did it because Anderson Cooper told me
that I should really release these
documents just to pick someone can you
imagine the outrage 24/7 on right-wing
media on Hannity on Rush Limbaugh on the
entire entire thing if Donald if Barack
Obama had done that and the double
standard here where Trump says listen
people I respect judge Janine Hannity
they said release the documents no I
didn't look at
because they told me to release him I
don't even know what it's all about
Obama would be destroyed if he had done
something similar yeah but we don't get
that sense of outrage when Trump does it
because we're so used to it we're so
desensitized to it and I feel like in a
way Trump wanted to declassify these
documents all along but he knew that it
would look bad in the public eye if he
did this because after all the
investigations into him right but does
it look better to say Hannity told me to
do it he's trying to say other people
encouraged me to do this yeah people
like Congress people and media figures
like Jeanine Pirro and Sean Hannity I
wouldn't be at all surprised if Hannity
gets pulled further into the Moller
probe because of his degree of contact
with Trump he's provided a platform for
Trump to push his lies in the apologia
about Russia he's tied directly to
Donald Trump's indicted former personal
lawyer Michael Cohen it would not be
even an iota surprising to me if Sean
Hannity ends up being a bigger figure of
interest in this entire fiasco send me
your thoughts what is going on here I am
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I want to
hear from you we'll take a quick break
and be back after this the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
brandon Kleckner brandon thank you we do
depend on the support of members and
patrons like brandon also want to say
thanks to andre rice who is our
long-term sustaining member of the day
people have been with us for a really
long time as members at this point and
Andres been with us since 2013 going on
five and a half soon-to-be six years for
Andre Brandon Andre thank you join them
support media that means something to
you
ww join pakman.com we're talking about
pennies a day pennies a day quite
literally and if you want to make a
pledge on patreon you can do that at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
starting at just $1 a month on patreon
both options very much important to the
continued growth and success of the
David Pakman show ok let's talk about
technocracy as well as Freudian slips a
couple interesting discussions from the
David Pakman show subreddit which you
can find at david pakman.com slash our
edie di t more than 7000 david pakman
show viewers and listeners now
participating I mention it to you
because we want to foment robust
community and conversation on that
subreddit note rolling though we have
moderators trolling not allowed there
was a post about technocracy saying
david what's your opinion on technocracy
title says it all here's hoping he's
going to read it well I did read it and
this is something I'm interested in so
first let's start with what is
technocracy when we talk about
technocracy we talk about a government
or control of society or control of
industry by a sort of elite of technical
experts who basically see governance as
an engineering problem so there are some
obvious pros to a technocracy number one
we put people in power who know things
instead of people who are professional
politicians or mostly lawyers which is
what we have in American politics today
at least at the national level so if you
have people who know things you would
think that that would be a positive
change in government government when you
have people who are actually subject
matter experts the problems with
technocracy are number one who decides
who the experts are because if I said
let's put in experts on climate science
to actually work in government the right
will line up a long list of people they
say are climate science and climate
change experts would we agree that these
are the experts on climate science and
climate change no we would not so that's
one problem with technocracy who decides
who the experts are number two experts
in which fields right how do we decide
which fields are the important ones for
governing and then there's an important
question that's sort of like a
chicken-egg question or a causation
correlation question are lots of
politicians lawyers because you need law
knowledge to be a politician or are lots
of politicians lawyers because being a
lawyer makes you better suited maybe
because of how you've been taught to
think for example to be a politician
along the same lines we might have
Tech's expert tech experts and
scientists elected as politicians
elected officials not because they need
that technology to do the job of being a
politician but because their background
in science their background in tech
maybe the argument would go makes them
better suited for the types of thinking
that elected officials should be doing
the answer probably is like most things
a gray area you don't want a total
technocracy you want a balance right now
we have way too few people from tech and
from science in government and
particularly at the federal level but at
the same time you don't want to go
completely overboard and get people from
other disciplines out of government what
we we can say with certitude is just
having lawyers run government is not
something that has served us
particularly well over the last many
many decades also from the David Pakman
show subreddit somebody pointed out
that I had a Freudian slip when I did
the show on was it Monday or Tuesday
Tuesday where I was talking about Donald
Trump's Supreme Court pick and I said
the following and Pat Pat noticed it as
well we have had yet another major
development in the confirmation of
Donald Trump Supreme Court prick pick
Brett Kavanaugh Supreme Court prick I
actually didn't even notice it when I
said it even though I corrected myself
that's interesting it went totally over
my head and it reminded me I think I I
don't remember all of the Freudian slips
that I've had on the David Pakman show
but one of my absolute favorites is this
one from over a year ago which I'll play
for you today Republicans Mike Lee and
Rand Paul voted against approving those
sanctions even Ted Cruz and [ __ ] Mitch
McConnell Freudian slip guys Mitch
McConnell excuse me uh Wow we have to
just continue right I mean let's you
have to keep going we'll edit that out
don't worry about it maybe the most
important element of this well we didn't
edit it out and I think that that
probably is the most notorious Freudian
slip on the show right what was going on
with that hair to seem so so different
yeah I know it's weird like I'm not
aware of having changed my hair for ten
years and I look back a year and I'm
like what on earth was going on at the
time it's very odd anyway thanks to
everybody who's participating daily in
the David Pakman show subreddit join the
conversation david pakman.com slash our
EDD i.t Donald Trump is now calling the
FBI quote truly a cancer in our country
when I read it I actually thought you
know Richard Nixon probably felt the
same way towards the end there he
probably would would have had a similar
point of view about the FBI the FBI is
not an objectively perfect or even
delightful organization there's this
really sort of complex dynamic that's
developed where merely by defending the
fact that the Trump Russia investigation
makes sense you have some on the Left
attacked four haphazardly supporting
such a dark institution as the FBI or
the CIA and supporting every bad thing
every Intelligence Agency has ever done
so let's start at the obvious the FBI is
not objectively great as an organization
it is an intelligence security and law
enforcement agency it's part of the
apparatus of so-called justice in the
United States it's run by people people
make mistakes
it has scandals it makes errors it's not
infallible
it's what I'm trying to say but it's
mere existence in and of itself isn't
the problem
much like the existence of the House of
Representatives isn't the problem the
problem is that much of the House of
Representatives has been overrun by
right-wing ideological lunatics so the
FBI is the FBI and allowing the right to
frame the FBI at a sort of institutional
level as the problem is problematic and
allowing the left to be framed as blind
haphazard defenders of the FBI is also a
problem because the FBI has done bad
things so that gets us to this week
Donald Trump did an interview with the
hill TV Hilda Hilda TV I guess it is
Donald Trump said during that interview
that the FBI's quote truly a cancer in
our country he's framing the existence
of the FBI and what it has done simply
by carrying out its duties to be some
kind of dereliction of their actual
duties and during this interview Donald
Trump presents what is really an
alternative reality in terms of with
what the FBI is doing or should be doing
Trump said this was all related to Trump
Russia Trump said during this interview
that the Trump Russia investigation is
quote one of the great scandals in the
history of our country using some of the
same language that we've heard from
Trump before and we've sort of become
accustomed to Trump said it's a hoax
beyond a witch-hunt Trump said during
the same interview with the hill TV
Comey was a bad guy I actually think
that the broader attacks on the FBI are
nothing more than a distraction because
they like to say you know the FBI did
bad things look at what the FBI did
under Hoover the FBI tried to get Martin
Luther King to commit suicide these are
fair criticisms right Police Department
do bad things
militaries do bad things but to use that
as the explanation for why the Trump
Russia investigation is bad is a version
of the of the genetic ad hominem fallacy
right
the FBI's Trump Russia investigation is
bad because the FBI once tried to get
Martin Luther King to kill himself
oxygen is bad because Hitler also
breathed oxygen right now the FBI is
investigating real dangers to American
democracy
you can say American democracy is broken
I'm with you but the investigation is in
two very real things Russia does this
they try to undermine democracy all over
the world they did the same thing in the
United States the only real check we
have right now is the judiciary and
investigations like this one that are
being carried out that by the FBI this
doesn't mean that the FBI is beyond
scrutiny this doesn't mean that the FBI
and the CIA and our military all of
these institutions have done bad things
in the past but the problem isn't the
FBI as an entity which is the problem
that Republicans claim to have and by
the way if you need more proof of that
Republicans seemed fine with the FBI
when it was investigating Hillary
Clinton it was fine when James Comey
made the decision to come out and say oh
you know what we are gonna take just
another look into the Hillary Clinton
stuff days before the November 2016
election they're not at odds with the
FBI Pat they're at odds with this
investigation and Trump is trying to
make it seem as though the FBI
institutionally is the problem yeah and
certainly Trump would have more
credibility if all along throughout his
entire life he was anti FBI like if he
called out the atrocities under J Edgar
Hoover or there Martin Luther King
situation no he kept quiet about it his
entire life only now that they're
investigating him is he outraged about
it you you think trump's keyed in on the
issue of MLK and the FBI or the nuances
of what happened under J Edgar Hoover
you think that that's an area of
expertise for MLK did so many great
things and people now are starting to
pay attention to it Oh
now right exactly we're only now
figuring out what happened then so this
is a and I know that most people in the
audience don't need to be told this like
I get that most people in our audience
understand that the criticisms of the
FBI are number one not actually
criticisms of this investigation like a
lot of us on the Left have been
criticizing these institutions for a
very long time but that doesn't mean
that every single thing they do needs to
be stopped or as problematic so I know
that a lot of people in our audience
don't need to be sort of given that
speech but the double standard with
which all of a sudden systemically the
FBI is the problem is the truly
laughable part what do you think about
this I hope that you are following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show where we will frequently
have polls about issues that come up on
the show like what's your opinion about
the FBI and lots of behind the scenes
pictures and much more follow the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show you can also follow me at david
pakman check out pictures from my recent
trip and much much more we will take a
break and come back we're going to talk
about productivity but it's not just
going to be here's how many cups of
coffee a day you should have that is
Pat's doing a special about that some
other day and we'll hear all about his
coffee drinking habits that's not what
the interview is about though it will be
about productivity as a sort of
institution that is now becoming
popularized
it's quick break back after this the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to be joined today by chris
bailey who is the author of two books
about productivity which have been
published in 13 languages hyper focus
how to be more productive in a world of
distraction and the productivity project
so Chris first of all thanks for talking
to me about this yeah thanks for having
me man so first place I want to start
before we get into some of the more
specifics is that I find the whole
productivity field interesting because
on the one hand for a long time I've
been delving into such questions as when
in the day am I most productive what
techniques for organizing my work would
be important to achieve maximum
productivity sort of the nitty-gritty of
it and yet at the same time Chris I am
concerned at the more social level about
the focus on more productivity all the
time because I believe that not being
productive in a sort of deliberate and
thoughtful way
is a really important thing for humans
to sort of be doing for our health
so the question one is how do we kind of
square those two sides yeah like what's
the point of productivity like that this
is an idea that I've struggled with
personally because the very idea that
you want to become more productive
implies on some level that you're not
entirely satisfied with where you're at
already but we're at where I like to go
is what strives at what drives me to
become more productive and ultimately
I'm a very lazy person I like to veg out
I like to read books in my spare time I
don't like to you know just work all the
time and so I think everybody comes to
productivity for a different reason but
I think the best reason to strive to
become more productive is so that we can
make more time for what's acts
meaningful to us in our spare time and
that the idea of productivity like it's
such a loaded term I find like what
comes to mind for a lot of people is
something that feels so cold and
corporate and all about this mindless
efficiency but I think it's something
that makes us more human because when
we're perfectly productive we accomplish
more of what we set out to while we
carve out more time for doing what we
want so I think like you hit the nail on
the head it's so critical to have a good
reason for wanting to become more
productive as opposed to just wanting to
do more more MORE
faster faster faster because that just
leads you to spend more time on
autopilot mode and not really accomplish
what's important in your life yeah and
here in the US it's become almost
fetishized like that is so busy right if
you if you're not busy they're almost
going to be judgements made as to what
what exactly is it that you're doing and
it seems that that's the sort of ugly
side of productivity the good one is the
one we're about to talk about but the
ugly side for me is the sort of becoming
the the ideal becoming to be so busy
that you have no time for friends or
family or relaxation and that do you how
do you when people come to you and they
say listen I want to be more productive
here's the list of a hundred things I
need to be fitting in how do you sort of
broach the idea that it might be
important to think about busyness and
productivity is two different things
like is that an idea yeah well yeah like
and I make the argument in hyper focus
that we've never been so busy while
accomplishing so little and productivity
it's not about how much we produce it's
about how much we accomplish over the
course of the day that's what we're left
with that's what's different in the
world because we live - or work the day
of our life and so do you produce you
know 100 emails and not accomplish a
single thing all day or do you actually
do things that progress your work
forward and so I find that you know when
when somebody says oh I'm so busy David
like it's essentially just a way for me
to say I'm so important and the world
needs me so much that it's asking for so
much for me and I'm so big
see I can't fit in anything you know the
biggest BS saying in the world is I
don't have time for that you know people
say I don't have time to to read a book
for example people have the time they
just spend it watching TV or on
Instagram or social media or vegging out
on Netflix you know it's so often we
when we say we don't have the time for
something and we're so busy it's we we
have the time we just spend it on other
things and so it's really like so much
of productivity in this way is about
taking that step back from what we're
doing in the first place so we can see a
what's important but B what we should be
focusing on in the first place so we
have that intention behind what we're
doing and you know if there's one thing
that I found in all this research by the
way I came at this topic from the
opposite direction wanting to do more
more more faster faster faster but the
more I explore about productivity the
more I realize it's not about doing more
faster it's about doing the right things
and doing those things with intention
and I like to focus a lot on attention
on how we focus because it's it's the
most limited ingredient we have to to
becoming more productive and when we
focus without intention behind what
we're doing it's essentially just wasted
energy and so you know that that's what
I'd say to that is that intention it has
to lie at the core of of everything we
do are there any universal truths about
productivity or is it really it depends
on the person and what I'm sort of
getting at is in his book when Daniel
pink talks about how great there are
night owls there are people who work
better sort of naturally in the morning
or middle and there's a sort of this
idea sometimes that you get your best
work done in the morning but it doesn't
really seem to be true for everybody so
are there any universal productivity or
efficiency ideas that you find hold true
for everybody there are but there are
very few you know that this is personal
productivity it's not economic
productivity for example and so it's
personal everybody's wired differently
everybody does different work everybody
chooses different things that
different productivity strategies that
resonate with them more strongly what
what bugs me more than anything in this
productivity space you know I've been
fortunate that I'm kind of like one step
removed from the productivity space I
like to filter out the research and the
advice that other people are giving and
call BS on the stuff that that is BS and
whenever somebody says like I have this
five this ten step system for getting
more done every day I immediately start
to question that person's an advice
because you know there are some general
truths like the things that contribute
to our productivity is one of them like
we need energy to be to burn in order to
be productive we need to be deliberate
about how we focus or else the world
will take control over our attention as
opposed to us but but the ways and we
need to manage our time as well
obviously but the ways by which we go
about doing those things and focusing
deeper and and harnessing how much
energy we have and managing our time are
different for everybody so this is
something that I like to encourage in my
books is take what works for you and
leave the rest because there's a lot of
BS out there and you should be
questioning questioning at all what
seems to be the right use of caffeine
within the space that we're talking
about Cheers
III view caffeine and alcohol as similar
constructs you know caffeine is a way by
which we can summon some energy from
later on in the day to use now and so
for hunkering down on like an important
conversation like this one if we're
hunkering down on writing something
important or an important meeting we can
use that energy boost for greater
productivity because we can have more of
us to give to to what we're doing in the
moment and caffeine kind of narrows our
attentional spotlight in on doing one
important thing at a time
and so you know we have to use that
boost wisely though because later on in
the day our energy you might experience
as if you caffeinate to to higher levels
your energy dips a little bit and and so
you might you know instead of using that
energy boost first thing in the morning
so you have more energy to go about your
daily ritual and reading the paper and
the news
maybe use it when you're just getting to
work and so you can actually benefit
from that I view alcohol in a similar
way as a way by which we borrow energy
as well as happiness from the following
day and so we you know we we get to have
a looser experience today at the price
of a worse one tomorrow but it actually
you know alcohol has been served has
been shown to make our attention less
inhibited while caffeine makes our
attention more inhibited so it makes
ideas more free-flowing and so maybe if
you're brainstorming at night having a
glass of wine with your you know your
notepad that you're scribbling on is a
helpful thing to do but god help you if
you need to focus after that point in
terms of the tasks that somebody might
do throughout the day I've experimented
with number one getting directly into
the ones the tasks that are either the
more complex ones or the ones I kind of
don't really feel like doing first to
feel like I have the most sort of
annoying stuff out of the way
I've also experimented with getting to
sort of the simpler easier tasks first
to start crossing a bunch of stuff off
of my to-do list the sort of small wins
approach get a bunch of small wins
earlier in the in the day do you have
feelings one way or the other about that
no I I don't and this is one of those
things where you gotta you know we all
have so much data at our disposal we
just need to look back at our own life
and this is I think one of the
frustrating things that that interviews
violent when chatting with me is like
productivity is personal like I offer up
a bunch of suggestions in my books and
stuff like that but you know III
personally find that that easing into
the day is is more effective for me but
then again I have more energy later on
in the day I struggle to get through the
mornings and so I would if I were to
offer up one suggestion with regard to
that I would say you know like what Dan
pink says it in his book when line up
when you do your most productive and
ugliest tasks with when you have the
most energy and so if you have if you
like having a cup of coffee in the
morning and in the morning you're one of
these people these weirdos who
spring out of bed are you one of these
people man basically I mean like within
Tom oh jeez I it takes me like a few
hours to ease end of the day I'm still
what is it I don't have my watch on but
it's like 10:00 a.m. and I'm still
easing into the day but but then again
like I'm cranking out work at 1:00 in
the morning and so I would say align it
with when you have the greatest amount
of energy do the ugliest tasks then you
know the things that lead us to
procrastinate are fascinating that there
are certain attributes that a task can
have that make us more likely to put it
off
whether task is boring whether it's
frustrating
whether it's difficult whether it's
ambiguous whether it is unstructured and
the more of these attributes that a task
has the more likely we are to put it off
for for another day and so if you find
that you have a lot of tasks like these
you know align those for when you have
the most energy maybe reward yourself
with a cup of coffee
you know our attention is fascinating
it's drawn like a magnet to anything
that we find pleasurable in the moment
to anything we find threatening in the
moment and to anything we find new and
novel in the moment and so if you look
at how technology companies structure
their apps and their devices your
smartphone for example it's probably the
most pleasurable threatening and novel
thing on the planet it's unlike it's
pretty much the opposite of the uglier
tasks on your plate and so you know part
of it is is aligning them to any of the
most energy but part of it also is
getting rid of these distractions so you
can carve out the room in which to focus
more deeply last thing I want to touch
on in the limited time we have is this
entire movement and milieu around
productivity basically a middle class
and higher thing in the West in other
words if you're doing shift work at a
factory the type of stuff you and I are
talking about and that you write about
doesn't really apply to you or is there
a way in which it does the the
distinction I think it largely is and
you know that that's an idea that I'd
have to incubate a bit more but the main
separation that that I've found in my
work is that
that when somebody does knowledge work
for a living you know there there are a
programmer there they're a writer there
they are a code or whatever might be
versus a factory worker there is very
little room for a factory worker to
become more productive you know if you
crank out eleven widgets instead of ten
you're ten percent more productive over
the course of the day but if you're a
programmer for example or somebody who
who does knowledge work for a living
you can crank out four hundred lines of
code instead of 200 that has ten
features instead of five that has zero
bugs instead of twenty and be you know
ten twenty times as productive and so I
think that's where the disconnect begins
to happen with productivity is when
somebody goes from doing assembly line
type work that's simple and repetitive
to work that's more complex and mental
so yeah III I think you know when that
Factory mindset it's all about that
efficiency work hard hard hard faster
faster faster but when we do this
knowledge work for a living but then
then all these other other ingredients
become so important our focus in in
addition to how well we manage our time
super interesting we've been speaking
with Chris Bailey author of two books
about productivity published in 13
languages hyper focus how to be more
productive in a world of distraction and
the productivity project Chris really
great time today
thanks so much for having me mate nice
to be here the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
this is a story about two major topics
that are important to me that I talk
about frequently one is the size of the
American military and defense apparatus
and two this is a story about Democrats
and Republicans being the same on too
many issues let's start with that second
part okay
I've told you at this point so many
times that Democrats and Republicans
aren't the same that voting for a
Democrat is not the same as voting for a
Republican at a sort of base general
level that on many important issues
they're extraordinarily different net
neutrality minimum wage social issues
abortion and gay rights education policy
many of them on health care there's this
very very long list of huge differences
between your average Democrat and your
average Republican at the federal level
but as I've said before on a ton of the
basic structural fundamental issues that
guide our politics Republicans and
Democrats are effectively the same so no
matter what their rhetoric is on
campaign finance they effectively both
perpetuate the status quo system that
got them into power in the first place
although some of them like to say I do
want to change the campaign finance
system no matter their rhetoric on
spending priorities they in the end when
the rubber meets the road mostly we'll
all participate in furthering this
constant growth of defense spending and
military spending at the expense of
funding other things the American
military is more than well-funded
millions of military personnel tens of
thousands of military aircraft thousands
of Tanks dozens are nearly two dozen I
think aircraft carriers dozens and
dozens of submarines we have endless
nuclear weapons bases all over the world
just like by a lot by a huge margin we
do the most military spending of any
country period it's not even close the
Senate recently passed a new defense
spending bill that increases the
military budget by another 17 billion
and the headline is act
which is Bernie Sanders was the only
Democrat to vote against this bill but
there's also more to it and you actually
do have to look into the details to
really understand what's going on here
93 senators voted YES on this bill six
suppose it fiscal conservatives in the
Republican Party voted against the bill
and Bernie one Democrat voted no on this
bill so I want to be clear there was
also health spending tied up in this
bill there was a government shutdown
riding on passing this bill so it's not
as simple as the headline say which is
Bernie's the only Democrat to vote no on
giving more money to the military
because yeah there was spending on
health that was in there and keeping
government open but this is exactly how
Democrats end up hiding behind and
getting away with mostly doing business
as usual with Republicans on defense
spending on military spending and
keeping the entire thing going and this
is how they play the game publicly
Democrats want this and Republicans want
that vote for me because I'll do X no
vote for me because I'll fund Y but then
they get together and they combine the
X's and Y's into one bill so when the
Democrats get slammed because hey you
guys are all funding an even bigger
military I thought you didn't want to do
that they can hide behind well listen
there was important health spending in
the bill there was important education
spending in the bill I wasn't going to
vote against that and that's true there
was important health and education
spending in the bill because that's how
they arranged it they agreed to have
military and health spending in the same
bill you don't have to do that the bills
don't have to be done in this way so is
it as simple as Bernie's the only dem to
vote against everybody else is bad no
it's not but enough Democrats should get
together Pat to say we got to separate
these provisions into multiple bills
it's us who decides how do we won't vote
on this stuff let's separate it and
kudos to Bernie Sanders for sticking to
principle here especially because
education and health care are big topics
of his and you know it's just
unfortunate that the defense spending is
always the third rail of
like you always just have to support it
it's never a question it's never a big
controversy in the media and you know I
mean very few Republicans were able to
go along with that too it's sad to see
that Bernie Sanders was the only
Democrat well but is it good for Bernie
because at the same time he did vote
against the health and spending at the
health and education spending like I get
it it passed anyway and in the end his
vote didn't make a difference but this
is how they get you because then later
they can say Bernie Sanders voted
against increasing education and health
care spending is this the man you want
represent right like so and it would
technically be true but it doesn't
really fit it doesn't tell us the spirit
of what it was that went on I think that
critique would fall flat on his face
though because Bernie's the one out
there pushing for Medicare for all in
free college so it the spirit of what's
being said there wouldn't hold true to
the American public I hope that you're
right I hope that you're right and of
course they get away with it and when
you go to them and say just separate the
bills right separate this stuff they'll
say oh but we're not there yet we can't
change that yet we've got to play the
game you know until we're able to get a
majority or if they have a majority
they'll say we can't really do that
right now we got to have a bigger
majority in order to be able to separate
the bills out and this is why we need to
vote but we've got to go beyond it right
like this is going to the level of we
need we need civil disobedience we need
to be thinking way bigger if we actually
want change here I've been telling you
for months now that no matter what the
polls say about Ted Cruz versus Beto
O'Rourke in Texas no matter who's
raising more money no matter how
deceptive and desperate Ted Cruz's
fundraising appeals are this is an
uphill battle and this is an uphill
battle for better or auric because
incumbency is powerful it's an uphill
battle because Texas is a place where
Republicans vote much more than
Democrats do and this is also because
there are more people out there who
might show up and just vote a straight
Republican ticket without having paid
attention to the details of Beto
O'Rourke versus Ted Cruz so we knew that
it was going to be difficult but we now
have acutely bad news there's a new
Quinnipiac poll which looked at likely
voters instead of registered voters
has Ted Cruz up 954 245 the argument for
doing a poll of likely voters instead of
registered voters is that listen there's
a lot of registered voters who aren't
going to vote on November 6th who
haven't voted for a long time so in
order to see who's winning we should
look at who is likely to vote when
Quinnipiac surveyed registered voters
the lead for Cruz had been as small as 3
but now they're likely voter model has
Ted Cruz up 9 so the importance Thing
Thing Thing to think about here is if
they're tied in one poll among
registered voters but Cruz's up among
likely voters like let's assume the
polls are correct you can deal with that
by just getting people to vote right
like turnout in these midterms is
anywhere from 25 to 45 percent if the
registered voters like Beto or Roarke
just get them to the polls and you can
swing the election on turnout that's
that's one thing the other thing to
think about is that likely voter models
understate the young vote because a
common question in figuring out if
someone is likely to vote is have you
voted before if you're too young to have
voted before the model may not consider
you a likely voter but this might be
your first time voting and you might be
damn sure that you're getting out there
and voting for better or work but it's
time for the left to get very active
here right whether it's phone banking or
donating or volunteering this is not
going to be an easy one and now is the
time to do it and really this might even
be a better headline for better or work
to get his supporters to vote right if
you see a headline that says I don't
know Beto up to maybe you stay home this
is a call to action and I hope people
will see it and not be discouraged by
Beto being down 9 in this poll yeah
there's an argument to be made that
Hillary Clinton lost because all the
polls had her up ahead of the election
though people who didn't really like
Hillary Clinton but certainly preferred
her over Trump just decided to stay home
because she was a shoo-in and that
didn't turn out so well yeah and it
didn't make a difference in California
but ultimately in the 77 thousand votes
that across three states ended up
handing Donald Trump the victory you
could say it did make a difference only
20-something I think in Wisconsin or
earlier
I mean 77,000 across three states
that's only about 25,000 per state but
that's why you need to think about every
race is 50/50 and think about it as
coming down to turnout and in reality
when turnout in the midterms is as
pathetically low it is as it is in the
United States I think sometimes midterm
turnout is like in the 20s I don't know
why I have 28 percent as like a midterm
turnout number from some prior midterms
but certainly not going higher than like
45 percent it's not wrong to think that
you can win on turnout alone
and hopefully better or or it can do it
but I told you that it was going to go
in the direction of Cruz as we got
closer to November 6 I don't think this
is any normal midterm though because
Donald Trump is so polarizing he's so
unpopular when it comes to the left and
I think that will cause progressives to
turn out and vote in Texas even if
historically there's a voter turnout
edge for Republicans in Texas maybe that
won't it won't happen this time because
everything really is new and I hope that
on November 7th and we come in all of
this stuff has come to fruition and we
have some good numbers to report to you
we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here is troy
york using one of his very poorly
disguised voices claiming that he knows
the real voter suppression that's going
on and he doesn't think i'm telling you
about it why don't you have a program
about voter suppression through the use
of polls and big polls and fake polling
geared towards getting people to think
that their vote don't matter is that it
no this is the reason we don't have
thankfully a dictator like another
Hitler like Hillary Clinton as president
this is a very confused individual I do
shows about voter suppression all the
time but let me tell you Troy or whoever
this guy is about the real voter
suppression the real voter suppression
is requiring forms of ID that while free
to obtain
require you to have documents that
aren't free
the real voter suppression is removing
people from voter rolls the real voter
suppression is reducing voting hours and
early voting strategically in places
that have disproportionately Democratic
vote am I making myself clear like
that's the real voter suppression the
problem is Troy York isn't making
himself clear like this you just want
one episode of the David Pakman show
dedicated to this yes or does he want an
entirely new program called like the
fake polls show like who's gonna pick
that up no station's gonna run that no
we would it would be a self-destructive
it would be more self-inflicted than
Trump's tweets about the Russia
investigation if we converted this into
the voter suppression show we've got a
great bonus show for you today we are
going to talk about why the United
States ranks at the bottom in a foreign
aid index very interesting and
potentially deceptive not deceptive but
confusing to some unusual results we'll
talk about that also there is the story
that has blown up about FanDuel saying
that it is not going to honor huge
payouts after what they claim was a
technical error and there are a lot of
people who are simply not buying that
explanation those stories and more on
today's bonus show two ways to get
access to it number one become a member
at wwlp.com
number two become a patron at at least
the $5 a month level patreon.com slash
david pakman show speak to you in just a
few seconds on the bonus check
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you